i don't care what you're going to do but
go out there and make something of
yourself for god's sake be an honest
person and work and get to the top of
whatever it is that you want to get to
the top of you get your act together a
bit discipline yourself see if you can
learn to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody world beater
everything should be equal everything
should be equally distributed we should
strive for equity it's like wrong
especially if you're a conservative
wrong what we want are just
hierarchies of competence not everyone's
a neurosurgeon if your father has a
brain tumor you probably want a
hierarchy of competence for
neurosurgeons so you can pick the one
that's the best so that he might not die
that's what a hierarchy of competence is
for for the postmodernist there's no
hierarchy that isn't based on power well
because they think the world runs on
power and that's why they're willing to
use power to get what they want because
it's the only thing they believe in but
a valid hierarchy of confidence it's god
we need those things man we need the
best plumbers we need the best
contractors we need the best carpenters
we need the best lecturers there has to
be a hierarchy of quality
not only so that we know who the best
are and to reward them properly but so
that we can reward them so they keep
being the best it's like if you have a
great educator if you have a great
leader if you have a great thinker you
want to reward them so they keep
thinking and they keep educating so they
can tell you something it's not a reward
for their intrinsic being it's a
calculated move on your part to suck
everything out of them that's valuable
as fast as you can that's what a
hierarchy of competence is for and the
idea that hierarchies of competence
don't exist is it's so cynical it's such
a pathologically cynical idea and it's
actually quite patently untrue because
here's an interesting tidbit from the
psychological literature let's say you
want to determine what the best
predictors are for lifetime success in a
western society well what would you hope
for how about intelligence there would
be a good one let's hope the smart
people occupy more positions of
complexity right because they're smarter
would you want it any other way okay and
then so and that's great the number one
predictor of accomplishment in western
societies is intelligence so that means
the system works what's the number two
predictor conscientiousness well what's
that it's a trait marker for hard work
so who who gets ahead smart people who
work hard now that doesn't account for
every bit of the difference between
people in terms of their hierarchical
structure because hierarchies aren't
perfect they're corrupt people get to
the top sometimes because they're
psychopathic although believe me a hell
of a lot less than you think because a
psychopath has to keep moving from place
to place because once he reveals himself
as deceitful and untrustworthy he has to
go find new suckers to fleece so the
idea that you know there's no
distinction between a ceo and a
psychopath it's like that's only made by
someone who a knows nothing about
psychopaths b knows nothing about ceos
and c has something
fundamental against the entire
capitalist structure because it's simply
not true corrupt sometimes greedy
sometimes short-sighted sometimes
running companies that are doing their
best to augur themselves into the ground
and so bad people running a dying
organization but generally speaking it's
not the case our hierarchies of
competence are reasonably functional and
not only are they functional they're
valuable we need to know who the
competent people are and we need to
reward them and even more importantly we
need to tell young people hey there's
some hierarchies of confidence out there
like a thousand of them go be a plumber
man but be a good one be an honest one i
had a plumber once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and he had put in
all the plastic piping and i was going
to test the joints they're supposed to
be glued together with this pipe glue
right and i said i told him i had to
test the joints and he said well you
don't have to test my joints they never
leak and i thought yeah that's okay how
about if i test them so i went up on the
third floor and filled the pipes with
water capping them in the basement like
you're supposed to like half an hour
later i had two inches of water in the
basement there were 30 leaking joints
that was the night before the drywallers
were supposed to show up well so he
wasn't particularly competent that's the
point of that story but even more so he
had put a bunch of the plastic pipe
outside where the drywall would be so it
would have been sticking through the
wall so i spent a frenetic night sawing
through the plastic pipe and re-gluing
joints so that the dry rollers could
come in what's the point if you're going
to be a plumber man be a good plumber
because otherwise all you do is go out
there and cause trouble we don't need
people to cause more trouble we need
people to solve problems you know and so
you can be a tradesman and you can be
you can make a lot of money as a
tradesperson it's a bloody reliable
honorable forthright productive way of
making a living and there is a hell of a
lot of difference between a working man
who knows what he's doing and one who
doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
bloody pleasure they tell you what
they're going to do they tell you how
much it will cost they go and do it it
works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you listen to these
panderers of the egalitarianism and
equity and they fail to recognize
completely that there are differences in
rank between people it's not such a
terrible thing man maybe you wouldn't be
a great lawyer like it's certainly
possible most people aren't but that
doesn't mean there isn't something you
could be great at there's lots of
hierarchies to attempt to climb and if
you fail in one
go trying another but the point is
you're still trying to aim for the top
and what the hell are you going to do if
you don't try to aim for the top flap
about uselessly and whine about your
life it's not helpful it'll just make
you miserable you're not reliable to
anyone you can't help out in a crisis
it's like so you tell young people and
this is another message for
conservatives like i don't care what
you're going to do but go out there and
make something of yourself for god's
sake be an honest person and work and
get to the top of whatever it is that
you want to get to the top of and that
stand up for yourself like a respectable
human being and be a bit of a light on
the world instead of a blight and you
can tell young people that and they
haven't been told that by anyone now and
so the young men are so hungry for that
that it's it's painful to watch they're
so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody world beater they think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting that might make
life for life worth living it's like
yeah it might so why don't you go do it
that's what the damn universities were
supposed to be teaching people they've
forgotten that i went to harvard month
ago month and a half used to teach there
and i talked to a bunch of students you
know and i told them it's not easy to
get into harvard you know and so why am
i saying that it's like these are high
quality kids so i told them what i just
told you it's like here you are at
harvard it's like get yourself educated
man read some books learn to talk learn
to think make yourself into something
get the hell out there and make the
world that put you here happy that you
were put there in that great institution
and they came up to me afterwards and
said god i wish someone would have told
us that when we were in our first year
it's like jesus why didn't someone tell
them that for god's sake it's supposed
to be the greatest university in the
world is it so difficult to figure that
out well it is if that is what you want
to have happen in the university you
want to make cringing milkshaws who
whine about being victims while they're
going to ivy league institutions jesus
it's pathetic
you